for the common man show that we hear
many times people will expose they'll
say that all the Muslim woman you know
they they got it all covered up she's
oppressed right what do you say when you
hear that as a Muslim woman who's
wearing hijab practicing Islam well I
can tell you from both ways from not
practicing you know being a
non-practicing muslim' I grew up in New
York and Brooklyn on Brighton Beach I
used to walk in a two-piece bikini on
the beach practically and my whole young
life and to someone who says that you
know Muslim moon is being pressed
because of the way she's dressed
absolutely not I see it the other way
because the expectations are very high
if you're you know not Muslim they're
very high everyone always wants to look
good exposes much private parts as they
can their husband walking around you
know displaying them know you are a
treasure and beauty you know and you
should be covered and that beauty is not
for everyone to see and that's what I
tell the people you know that I work
with they're asking me well you're so
covered it must be hot no I'm not hot I
used to be more hot when I used to be on
the beach or on that boardwalk or
outside wearing nothing yes then the Sun
hits your skin and you sweat a lot more
here you're covered you know and you're
not that hot I love it I I do not feel
any kind of I don't miss anything that I
have done before you know if I want to
go and you know in a bathing suit or
whatever I have my backyard is fully
covered and I can do that you know
there's nothing I go to the beach I go
just like this it's funny it's no
problem it's great I don't have to worry
about people seeing me seeing my fat
seeing my this thing like that all my
imperfections you know it's not for
anyone to see it's only for your husband
and your family